[Music]
gxk the new Empire is gearing up its
trailer release between November 30th
and December 1st in ccxp okay so for
those who don't know ccxp originally
called Comic-Con experience is an
entertainment and comic convention it is
based on the San Diego ComicCon and has
attractions and contents about Comics
television series movies Video Games Etc
it is the largest Pop Culture Festival
in the world and it is held in Brazil so
get ready for GX anyway let's get back
to the topic at hand will Godzilla
evolve and change in the new Empire is
there any evidence or Theory to support
this claim and if so why will he evolve
to answer these questions we should
first take a look at how Godzilla from
the monsterverse to be clear has changed
over the years and his change in design
and appearance isn't just the fanciful
work of artists that want to put out
their own versions but his changes and
metamorphosis are in fact rooted in lore
and there are specific reasons as to why
and how he keeps changing so let's
explore this by looking first at the g
man's 2014 appearance then the kotm
version the GVK iteration and how the
Monarch series will actually showcase
his change in real time and finally what
will he look like in
gxk the most diverse iteration of
Godzilla was introduced with a more
Square phase with a broad neck and also
the addition of gills this Godzilla's
eyes are small though and possesses
golden yellow coloration with relatively
small and not uniformly aligned teeth
the head and neck exhibits a forward
leaning posture creating a reptilian
look distinct from previous more malean
designs which are more upright the dors
plates though smaller than those of the
the Japanese counterparts relatively to
the body size maintain just an essence
of the maple leaf shape rather they are
sharper and Jagged in appearance
Godzilla's claws are enlarged in Black
while his feet take on a wider
elephantine look the skin is more
noticeably crocodilian in texture
characterized by a dark gray coloration
and having an overall bulky appearance
in king of the monsters a slight
restyling occurred with the dorsal
plates adopting more protrusions being
Maple Leaf shaped the classic design and
having a rougher skin the eye color
remains consistent but shifts to a
bright blue coloration during his
intimidation displays and also during
shooting of the atomic breath notably in
Godzilla versus Kong Godzilla's physique
remains largely unchanged maintaining
the recognizable features with the
director Adam Wingard opting for visual
consistency and appreciating the dorsal
fin design introduced by Michael Dy also
in the upcoming Monarch Legacy of
monsters Godzilla is set to Showcase two
distinct designs one reminiscent of the
2014 film during the 1950s flashbacks
and another in 2015 identical to the
former but featuring The 2019 style
dorsal plates highlighting a narrative
Evolution and regeneration of the iconic
Kaiju character design personally I
think that Monarch the legacy of
monsters will cement the fact that
Godzilla's change in appearance is
really in his nature in the monsterverse
lore and not just the whim of a CG
artist they will showcase the 2014
version as will be seen in the 1950s and
then also show the 2019 version as will
be seen in its 2015 time frame to add to
this there will also be flashbacks of
the muto San Francisco battle where he
will Dawn the straighter plates this
will lead to an explanation in the
series that a change was due to the
battle with the muto Prime which we
might or might not get to see I don't
know they will also state that Godzilla
has massive regeneration capabilities as
well as a transformational capability
and also give us an idea on how much
time he needs to reform his body parts
now will the king of the monsters make
another evolutionary leap will he change
again and why well we first have to ask
why did he change after the muto Prime
battle the answer is that his plates
were shattered into pieces and for the
first time ever he was outmatched by
another more powerful species therefore
he grew bigger had bigger dorsal plates
lost his belly fat and increased his
energy output to counter the muto EMP
dampening abilities this is evolution in
real time which pushed his body to make
drastic changes in order to be at the
top of the ladder now in gxk we might
see another change due to one important
fact the emergence of deadli rival
Titans so according to a potential toy
leak and information from gxk the new
Empire on the towho kingdom Forum
Godzilla's new designed in the upcoming
installment was tentatively named
evolved Godzilla featuring several
notable changes notably Godzilla has
undergone a transformation with a lean
of physique accompanied by larger scales
on his back the most prominent
alterations are observed in his limbs
where spiked elbows and sharper claws
contribute to a more menacing and a
formidable appearance the dorsal plates
a signature feature of Godzilla have
been redesigned and it is intriguing to
note that they mold from the old plates
indicating a dynamic and evolving aspect
to this Godzilla's character so just
like Godzilla single point evolved in a
matter of days or even hours from
aquaticus to the ultimate form and also
how Shin Godzilla underwent several
metamorphosis stages in the course of a
few days to change according to the
dangers and challenges he faced so will
Godzilla in the merse follow this
established theme that the goeras aren
really a stagnant species even their
Origins tell of a mutation factor that
changed their earlier forms into the
Kaiju entities so it isn't far-fetched
and dare I say even expected that
Godzilla should have certain Visible
Changes for his fifth installment in the
monsterverse it's actually quite due
let's not forget his temporary assisted
change from normal to burning form in
kotm as well
so now the main question is how much of
damage and Trauma would he endure in the
movie to cause him to evolve or will he
change due to his experience and battle
against Mecca Godzilla which again
showed him that he still have to improve
and adapt and evolve so that's about it
I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video if you're more interested in other
movie monsters and creatures then check
out our Channel we might just have
things that you haven't seen like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care fam